the bridge connecting Crimea to Russia
has partially collapsed after being hit
by a large explosion Russian authorities
say that three people were killed and is
blaming the blast only track bombing
social media video shows an explosion on
the roadway span of the bridge Russia
says it's setting fuel train Ablaze on
the adjacent railroad span Russian
President Vladimir Putin opened the
bridge in 2018 after Russia illegally
annexed the Ukrainian peninsula
from all we are now joined by DW
correspondent Matthias balinga who is
now in Ukraine's city of Nikolai hello
Matthias tell us more about Ukraine's
official reaction to the incident
yeah Ukrainian officials haven't said
much about it of course there's a lot of
speculation on how and by whom this was
uh conducted this attack whether it was
which seems a little to most people at
the moment the most likely version uh by
a truck loaded with explosives or
whether it was some kind of a airstrike
Rockets most probably
um but the Ukrainian officials haven't
said much about it
um there was a tweet by uh the
presidential advisor Michael podolia who
kind of owned it saying that every
territory must be
returned and this was a legitimate
Target as it was an illegal construction
but there's not much more than that
there's also been speculation about
Ukraine's Secret Service which has
denied any commend okay now are we from
the officials you've been talking to
other ukrainians what have they been
saying
well we've just been somewhere outside
of town where old people they were
working in their Gardens and staying in
these dutchers these summer houses and
they were saying they were celebrating
today
um and that's pretty much the mood all
across the country the strike has been
expected
um the Ukrainian postal service has even
issued a stamp uh about the destroyed
Bridge of course not with pictures from
today but with drawings and uh the the
government has said several times that
they consider this a legitimate Target
so it was more a question of when and
how and whether it would be possible
than whether they would attempt it it's
seen as a legitimate Target in the whole
of the country and then lots of memes on
the internet celebrating this memes for
example showing president zielinski
grilling meat skewers Over The Burning
Bridge or a high mass or rocket launch
swimming on the sea on on a rubber boat
next to the bridge all kinds of a meme
celebrating this okay DW correspondence
Matthias balenga reporting from
Ukraine's CT of Mika live thank you
now let's dig even deeper way to Frank
ledwich a military analyst who joins us
from Oxford hello Frank so Russia has
launched an investigation saying that a
track was blown up on the bridge what
are your thoughts on this
well lady that's the Russian account the
ukrainians are not going to say anything
about their assault
because of course if and when the bridge
is reconstructed they may want to have
another go but the inquiry that
President Putin whose birthday it is of
course today uh I suppose that's what
surprises are all about uh so this
inquiry that President Putin has ordered
will be looking at and we'll be looking
into all this in some detail my own view
is that there's probably a little bit
more to it than a truck I doubt it was a
missile the ukrainians don't have
missiles with that range
demolitions Experts of course spend
their lives on this kind of operation
this is a dream for military saboteurs I
have a suspicion that may have been
something about maybe a submersible
involved or perhaps pre-laid explosives
but we'll see we'll see what uh what
comes out of this as I say the Russians
they're saying it was a truck and that's
probably they're going to remain their
story okay here's the thing though
Ukraine hasn't taken any direct
responsibility but it's officials
celebrated the incident online if it
actually was Ukraine why wouldn't they
officially claim responsibility
they avoid claiming direct
responsibility for attacks such as
belgarad and other
ammunition dumps and installations
inside Russia over the last seven or
eight months
let's not forget this is whatever the
Russians say it is a key part of Russian
infrastructure but look there have been
leaks as Matthias said everybody knows
who did it there's no doubt about it and
whether it's formally announced or not
this was a Ukrainian operation you said
it's a significant part of Russia's
infrastructure tell us how significant
is this bridge
most of Russia's military supplies
heading towards the front that Matthias
was on up at Nikolai of curse on
novakova comes through over that bridge
there's 36 000 tons a day of material
people and fuel across that bridge and
it's gonna it said that the function of
the bridge simply cannot be replaced
what the Russians will have to do now is
use ferries they have got some military
transport there to replace some of the
military carrying capability
but uh it simply won't come near to the
the capacity of the bridge
their big problem now is that a lot of
the traffic will come down through the
town of militar which is just North West
actually mariopol and that puts it puts
the supplies to Crimea right within the
range of of Ukrainian artillery who can
exercise let's say an influence over
that so it's a vital artery into the
Crimea I mean Russia is obviously not
happy about this particular incidence
what could be their response to this
yes Eddie that's that's the that's the
key question here there's a lot of quite
understandable Jubilation about this but
it won't go unanswered
now this is the first significant strike
on on a Russian territorial key
infrastructure item of key
infrastructure it's outside the
Ukrainian territory from the Russian
perspective of course from the Ukrainian
perspective it isn't
what we saw last week with respect to
the pipes in the North Sea
what the Russians indicating a
capability that's my analysis to be able
to strike outside their territories of
course we know they can and I have a
suspicion that's where the response may
come not within Ukraine itself but
outside Ukraine and that might be a a a
another step along the escalatory path
that we're already on
we'll have to wait and see how that
develops but thank you very much Frank
letvich Military analyst for your time
thanks Eddie